second words that means something
completely different after getting a dog
doorbell a bell or chime used to signal
that someone is at the door after fire
alarm dishes and expected chore
following every meal after an unexpected
group activity and a possible treat
alarm clock a device for alerting you at
a certain time usually for waking up
after a wet nose prodding your face
usually for feeding off to no longer
beyond something after where your dog
knows it shouldn't be but all
practically his or her name quiet peace
free from disturbance or noise after
definition not found
free time do the time available for
leisure activities after due to the time
available for hanging out with you know
who on think we should go to go to tour
by 5 turkeys roast them all breed Lucy
bit describing everything about a dog
you could potentially own after you are
such a weird-looking luck describing
everything about a dog
except what might make one special to
you
well you're pretty great you spot
somebody how do stuff your entire body